So let's summarize our breadth first search try number 1.
So this algorithm has some great properties.
It's completely parallel, and there's no direct communication or synchronization between threads at all.
There's very little thread divergence.
The memory behavior isn't ideal since it involves gathers and scatters, but it's not bad.
Unfortunately, the host has to control the iterations, which isn't super attractive,
though we'll look at a new feature in CUDA 5 in the next unit called Dynamic Parallelism
that allows the GPU to control the iterations directly,
but the real problem is the quadratic complexity.
We're going to have perfectly data parallel work,
but we're going to do way too much of it.
This approach will scale poorly as we process larger and larger graphs,
and we are not cool with that at all.